[Music]
while playing with the ball
nora gets curious about its motion
as she drops the ball on the floor she
asks herself
what will be its speed as it reaches
midway in its path
she drops the ball from a height one
meter above the ground
it covers 50 centimeters to reach the
midpoint
nora knows that it took one second for
the ball to reach the midpoint b
with this information can she find the
speed of the ball
exactly when it's at point b
like you'd probably be thinking nora
also thinks
the speed of the ball will be the
distance traveled by it
divided by the time taken to reach that
point
so she comes up with the answer 50
centimeters per second
or 0.5 meters per second
but is this the speed of the ball when
it's at point b
no it's not this answer would have been
correct
if the speed of the ball was constant
throughout its motion
but we know that the speed of the ball
increases as it falls
so the answer nora got is actually the
average speed of the ball
as it reaches the position b but what we
are interested in
is the speed exactly at the instant when
the ball is at position b
that is called the instantaneous speed
of the ball
can you try finding the instantaneous
speed
let's see what happens at the instant
the ball is at position b
the distance traveled by the ball at
this instant is zero
and the time elapsed at this instant is
zero
so we get the speed to be zero divided
by zero
which is undefined doesn't make any
sense right so how do we then find the
instantaneous speed of the ball
calculus is the branch of mathematics
that helps us answer this question
how we will see that in the later
section of this course
but wait another thought puzzled nora
as she drops the ball she wonders why
the ball ever reaches the floor
this might seem to be a lame thought but
don't forget that nora is smart
she thinks that mathematically the ball
should never touch the ground
so what was her thought process let's
see
suppose she drops the ball from a height
one meter above the floor
now to reach the floor first the ball
has to cover half this distance
to reach point b then the ball has to
cover
half of the remaining distance that is
one fourth of a meter
then the ball has to cover the next half
then the next half
and so on it means the number of steps
the ball has to cover
to reach the floor does not end that is
there are infinite number of steps the
ball has to perform
and to perform these steps the ball
takes an infinite amount of time
so according to this logic nora thinks
the ball requires
an infinite amount of time to reach the
floor
therefore the ball should never reach
the floor right
do you also think the same do you think
nora went wrong somewhere
share your thoughts in the comment
section
actually nora isn't the only one who was
puzzled by this
many centuries ago the same thought
puzzled a greek philosopher
zeno of ilia this is usually referred to
as
xenos dichotomy paradox even though we
know that when we drop the ball
it reaches the floor this logical and
mathematical conclusion
tells us that it should never reach the
floor
again a satisfactory answer to the xenos
paradox
is provided by calculus
we saw two examples here that calculus
can give us the answer to
but before looking at the central ideas
of calculus we will further explore what
other real-life problems calculus
can help us with
if we're on a cliff next to the sea it's
always tempting to randomly throw stones
into the sea
it's so much fun right but have you ever
wondered about the best possible way to
throw a stone
such that it covers the maximum distance
knowing this was certainly important in
the past to
attack the enemy ship now let's get back
to our question
if we throw a stone too high we know it
will not cover maximum distance
what to feed through the stone
horizontally
maybe not by experience we know
instead of throwing the stone
horizontally if we throw it at an angle
it will cover greater distance
of course the answer also depends on the
speed with which you throw the stone
let's say if you apply all your energy
you can throw it with a speed v
so if we throw the stone with a speed v
at what angle should we throw it
to cover maximum possible distance
as the angle at which we throw the stone
changes
the distance covered by it changes
and this is where calculus comes into
play
to get the answer we need to know how
the distance covered by the stone
changes
as the angle we throw it at changes
and this is exactly the kind of problem
that calculus helps us with
all right so calculus helps us with
analyzing things in motion
for instance finding the instantaneous
speed of an object
or finding the angle at which to throw
the stone
but wait let me ask you a completely
random question
look at this trajectory of the stone
what do you think will be this area
under the dashed curved path
we know how to find the area of a simple
shape like the rectangle
its area is equal to its length time its
width
but how do we get this formula
let's say the length of the rectangle is
5 centimeters
and its width is 10 centimeters then the
area of the rectangle
is 50 square centimeters so what does
this mean
it means that if we take a square tile
of length of one centimeter
that is a square tile of area one square
centimeter
then 50 such tiles will cover this
rectangle
now let's get back to our question what
will the area be
under this curve should we cover this
area also with square tiles
this will not work right look at the
square tiles covering the curve
we have a problem here as they don't fit
perfectly
then how can we figure out this area
you would have guessed by now that
calculus helps us to find the answer
we know the area of simple shapes like
rectangles
triangles polygons and so on
here are the formulas this is easy
because straight lines are involved but
the shapes that we encounter in our
daily lives
are not that simple as curves are
involved
that's where calculus comes into the
picture
so we've seen that other than finding
the instantaneous speed of an object
and the angle at which to throw an
object to cover maximum distance
calculus also helps us to find the area
of different shapes
in this course about calculus we will
explore each of these examples
in detail but before moving on
let's have a glimpse at the central idea
around calculus
this idea was used by greek
mathematicians to find the area of a
shape
long before calculus was developed
consider this circle with radius r
how would you find its area
consider these two triangles one
circumscribed around the circle
and the other inscribed inside it
we can say that the area of the circle
will be between the areas of these two
triangles
now what if we used squares instead of
triangles
we will get a better approximation of
the area of circle
if instead of triangles we used squares
we can further improve our results if we
used pentagons
did you get the idea can you tell me how
we can improve the approximation
further as we consider polygons with
greater number of sides
we will get close to the circle
the area of the polygon inscribed in the
circle
and the area of the polygons
circumscribing the circle
get closer to each other this was the
method used by greek mathematicians
to find the area of the circle it's
called the method of exhaustion
this is the central idea of calculus
used to solve the problems we mentioned
above
with this knowledge do you think we can
solve our problem of finding the
instantaneous speed of an
object think about the ways in which you
can approach the problem
and share your thoughts in the comments
section
in the next part we will see how to find
the instantaneous speed of an object
and the idea applied to calculate the
area of a shape
we will also discover that these two
ideas are related to each other
see you in the next part